twitches biggest name has left the
platform ninja will now be exclusively
streaming on mixer so what the hell does
that mean
so before I get into all the reactions
about ninja moving what the hell is
mixer well as far as I can tell
mixer and twitch are almost identical
which is owned by Amazon whereas mixer
is owned by Microsoft and both offer a
in browser or app streaming experience
that is more or less the same even if
you go take a look at the actual mixer
site it looks exactly like twitch with a
different color scheme it has its own
version of bits and the chat looks the
same it's almost fury how similar there
it's that similarity and the fact that
both of these platforms are owned by
massive corporations that to me makes
this so significant over the last few
years as twitch has been exploding it
sometimes feels like it's had this
pseudo monopoly over the streaming world
all the biggest names that's where you
find them but what's happened here is
mixer has almost hostile II come in and
taken ninja offered him a real contract
with reported figures of up to ten
million dollars a year in order to
jumpstart their streaming platform maybe
the simplest way to put it is this is a
big dick move from Microsoft they went
out they got the biggest streamer
possible brought him to their platform
to kick-start it it's hard to understate
just how much this move is breaking the
status quo from what we've seen with
twitch they're offering ninja guaranteed
money to come over and stream they're
offering three subs on his channel for a
limited time to get them started on the
platform as I'm sure many of you know
the way that twitch works with massive
personalities like ninja or Tim the tap
man or T foo is they have a revenue
sharing agreement where you get
subscribers to your channel and
donations and that's how you make money
but you share some of that with twitch
for them letting you use their platform
well what's happened here is a complete
reversal they're offering him guaranteed
money the way that a sports franchise
would sign an athlete in almost every
way possible that's flipping the script
on what it means to be a big-time
streamer this move pulls ninja away from
the traditional agreement where twitch
owns the platform and he shares money
with them while he's on the ground
working hard every single day to get
subs get donations and create endless
content but now ninja is the spectacle
not twitch now ninja can operate on
stream in a way that we've never seen
before from streamers I'm sure you've
seen it and I've seen it too your
favorite streamer you know dips a little
bit of viewership or you could tell that
somebody subs are falling off a little
bit because they've been away from their
stream for a couple weeks now ninja can
stream without any of that pressure he
can focus on content and get back to the
streaming routes that he was talking
about in that announcement did you I
just feel like I'm gonna get back to you
no back to the streaming routes and
that's what it's all about and to say
the very least this ninja announcement
must be tantalizing if you're another
huge streamer looking to solidify your
career for the next ten years if I'm
sitting in the seats of someone like dr.
disrespect or tea food or shroud any of
these guys that are averaging big
numbers I'm looking at twitch and I'm
looking at mixer saying how can I get
myself a guaranteed contract we are
already seeing people tweeting and
speculating that this might be not the
first move to mixer but one of many and
for me I'm excited to see how twitch
reacts to this and also Amazon by
extension because Microsoft is clearly
making the point that there's gonna be
competition in this world so one of the
first things I saw when this
announcement was made was all of the
risk associated with ninjas moves people
were speculating that oh well people
aren't gonna jump to mixer just to
follow ninja and he's gonna lose
viewership and what happens to all of
his subs there's obviously a real
disconnect from his base on Twitch and I
do agree that there has to be some
amount of risk there but you got to
think a little bit deeper than that
ninjas not going anywhere on Twitch if
you tuned in to doctor Lupo's channel or
Tim's channel you're still gonna see him
in client in fortnight and on discord in
cause with these guys
the stardom that is ninja it's not going
anywhere and the fact is the move he
just made gives him a guaranteed
contract which means he never has to
worry about this kind of stuff again and
if twitch wants to take away his check
mark five minutes after he makes this
announcement it's just actually no skin
off his back at this point to me as
someone who's paying attention it kind
of seems like ninjas getting bigger than
fortnight and bigger than twitch in a
way i remember just a few weeks back him
reacting to someone in chat on stream
and just saying look I don't care about
subs anymore
don't I don't stress out too much about
sub count anymore like at all
now that we've seen this announcement I
guess we know why all right so let's
walk this back a little bit mixer this
platform owned by Microsoft buys ninja
well how can a company spend this much
money on one stream well if you really
think about it ten million dollars a
year is pennies when you think about a
company like Microsoft's advertising
budget we've seen for the last year all
these hashtag ads on twitch where shroud
might play a new FPS game as a
sponsorship deal well I don't see this
as much more than that
mixers just decided that the best way to
bring people to their platform is to go
out get the biggest fish on Twitch and
give them as much money as they can to
bring people with them
the big question that remains to me here
is who follows what's gonna happen our
other big streamers gonna go to mixer is
twitch gonna come out and start signing
people to contracts there's a lot of
wheels that have been set in motion by
this move and in a lot of ways I feel
like that was ninjas intention he's now
open the floodgates for other creators
to go out and fight for the exclusivity
and the job security that they really
deserve I mean after all these guys are
massive celebrities and to go a little
bit deeper on this I think it's worth
considering what it does to the content
itself you know for the last year so
Ninja has had a pretty clean cut channel
it's actually been one of the biggest
criticisms of him from sort of the
traditional gaming world he's a little
bit PG a little bit kid-friendly
for what we expect to see on the
Internet if you're gonna go out and
pursue deals like this like Hollywood
celebrity money this is it really to
your benefit to be creating a kid front
of the environment like that it's
something like Microsoft really gonna
want to go after someone like doctor
disrespect or xqc these guys who are
making a living basically off breaking
the rules it's two things to me it's
obvious that this can only be a good
thing it takes a massive influential
force like ninja to break the status quo
in a world where companies like Amazon
and Microsoft have the final say on
things and even if this doesn't work
even if ninja viewership falls and he
doesn't end up on mixer in the next
couple years that doesn't mean that it
failed he challenged that status quo and
he
showed a path that has never existed to
creators before and from where I'm
sitting this is going to be felt through
all levels of content creation it can
only benefit the small guys at the
bottom that these guys are being treated
like the celebrities that they are the
fact of the matter is ninja is a symbol
of a group of people that have grinded
to the top of Twitch's ladder to the
point where they're untouchable and now
the ball is in Twitch's court these guys
are not going to stop growing people
aren't gonna stop watching people play
games and if they want to keep them
around they've got to make a move thanks
for watching if you want more content
like this hit the sub button and ring
that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else hit up our Instagram
Twitter and Facebook pages
[Music]